welcome to hannity all right tonight we
are tracking multiple breaking stories
including shocking horrific
details from that sixth woman now
accusing andrew cuomo of sexual
misconduct now
a report from the albany times union out
tonight
this cuomo staffer who has not been
named as of yet was allegedly assaulted
inside the governor's private residence
while
she was on location to supposedly fix an
issue with his mobile phone he claims
the governor shut the door
isolated the pair in a room and then
proceeded to fondle her body
under her blouse governor cuomo was
denied the allegation
but if true this alleged sexual assault
could spell the end for
governor andrew cuomo much more on this
coming up tonight plus
straight ahead we'll have the very
latest from our crisis
at the wide open southern border our
investigative team
is back on the ground at the border
tonight in the great state of arizona
by the way senator mark kelly where are
you on this crisis
that is emerging are you denying it's a
crisis also
the people of arizona deserve to know
and later we'll have a full report
on the democrats latest efforts to
destroy your second amendment
and this is not a test this is indeed a
clear and present danger to your second
amendment rights
but first just after 9 p.m on the east
coast 6 p.m on the west coast
that means it's approximately oh two
hours or so after joe biden's betty time
now it's likely fat he's felt likely
fast asleep
after what has been a very long and
exhausting week
for the president yesterday he managed
to have
one agenda item and hold one public
event
again today just one very short scripted
speech
where he was struggling to keep his
focus on the tiny little letters and
words in the teleprompter
just look specifically look at his look
at his eyes here
he's digging in deep locking in not
glocking out
just to get through those prepared
remarks
joe does one event a day uh
it kind of looks like he needs a nap
desperately
of course still no press conference
still no joint address to congress
that would be called the state of the
union still his vice president kamala
harris is
taking solo calls with world leaders
that would be the commander-in-chief's
job
but hold on to your socks because
according to a very generous fluff piece
in politico the biden blitz is coming
it's now coming this article claiming
biden has been
hunkered down for weeks not because he's
struggling cognitively or weak or frail
or incapable of speaking well completely
coherently
but because he's had to organize the
vaccination distribution plan
you know the one that donald trump had
already organized
and handed over to him along with three
different vaccines
trump gave him those two and joe truth
be told
had absolutely nothing to do with the
1.9 trillion dollar
schumer pelosi payoff bill joe didn't
write it nor did he negotiate it
but now get ready america because
politico claims
that biden will probably hold more
public events in coming weeks
including tomorrow's prime time speech
about covert 19
and of course the upcoming state of the
union address
now let me make a prediction joe's been
practicing probably all week for the
speech tomorrow night
he'll do fine it'll be a short 15-minute
rah-rah we're doing great speech things
are turning we're turning the corner
uh and it'll be over he'll have
practiced all day yes
all day today all day tomorrow with
practice all day today
it will be a short scripted speech
they'll make the font really really big
so he doesn't really have to squint and
dial in the way we saw it today
as much as usual and joe will probably
also
yeah he can survive the state of the
union address and we're going to be
honest completely truthful
it's probably the easiest speech
anybody's ever giving
because you read two lines then you
pause for all the applause
you read three more lines then you pause
for all the applause
it's actually perfectly suited for joe
slow
comfortable pace for joe biden perfectly
suited for somebody that is frail and
weak
and struggling cognitively i'm sure
they'll probably get a bigger prompter
than usual
and of course after an adequate
performance during both those speeches
people are going to say see sean hannity
he's totally fine
there's one big problem anyone with eyes
and ears can see and hear that joe is
not totally fine
our sources close to the white house are
describing
how complete panic has set in in all
things biden's world
yesterday's brand new rasmussen poll
revealing half of the country is now
worried that joe biden
is not physically or mentally up to the
job
has added dramatically to the
behind-the-scenes panic in the biden
white house
a brand new op-ed in the washington time
reads quote
it's time to question biden's mental
health
this is why we got that biden
team leaked the fluff piece to politico
about the so-called biden blitz
let me be clear there won't be a blitz
you know the hardware store yesterday
oh here's a hammer mr president will you
answer a question
okay thanks guys we got to go it's going
to be that kind of
blitz now president trump usually talk
to the press pretty much every day
every night frankly might have talked
too much to the press
multiple public unscripted events by the
way i don't think donald trump
was ever asleep before 1am during his
entire presidency
and i doubt he ever slept more than five
hours in his adult life
that was a blitz this so-called biden
blitz on the other hand will
probably consist of him giving a few
speeches
written by his staff kept relatively
short
along with a few heavily orchestrated
and controlled public outings
but it won't matter we can already see
that joe
lost if he ever had one as fast ball his
curveball
knuckle ball even a slow pitch we
actually have real video to compare joe
biden
joe biden in 2012 joe biden in 2016
versus joe biden from just just the last
three weeks
this is only video of joe from the last
three weeks and you compare it to 2012
and 2016
and as always we let you decide
he sent me two letters saying by the way
can you send me some stimulus money for
companies here
in the state of wisconsin we sent
millions of dollars
i uh you know but the idea that um over
500 i think it's
i have a card i carry a card with me
every day with the total number of
folks who have been affected now they
got a new plan trust me
it's not going to cost you any more
folks follow your instincts on this one
i want to thank
the the former general i keep calling in
general
my my uh the guy who runs that outfit
over there
i want to make sure we thank the
secretary
they put one foot in front of the other
they keep going
that's the unbreakable spirit of the
people of america
that's who we are and representatives
uh cheryl shirley jackson lee
al green sylvia garcia lizzie pinelli
excuse me pinell and uh what am i doing
here
i'm gonna lose track here what am i
doing i'm going to lose track
that would be lose track again once
again we will ask the question
the media mob is afraid to ask but they
know what's happening what is going on
with the president of the united states
of america joe biden
is there something medically wrong here
we the people have a right to know
i've had enough of people telling me
hannity you need to be a little more
compassionate
to joe i actually do have compassion
it's painful to
watch this is supposed to though be the
leader
of the free world this isn't about one
person this is supposed to be
our commander-in-chief it is the hardest
job on earth
which is why the media mob and big tech
should not have created
what i described as the candidate
protection program
and either he's up to the task of this
big job or he is not
and it matters big time for the entire
world
now if you want to talk about compassion
i would argue compassion
should have come from all the people
around joe
biden that knew of his struggles and
worked
overtime to hide and cover up
all of this and purposely hide
vital information about a presidential
candidate
from you the american people where was
their compassion for joe
like for example joe's friends in the
media mob
had no problem raising cognitive
concerns about ronald reagan and john
mccain
let's take a look at this report from
the associated press again
you decide if he wins the general
election he'll be the oldest person to
assume the presidency
he's getting on the upper end of the
comfort zone for americans who wonder
whether he's going to have sort of the
vigor and the health
as president mccain's opponent barack
obama will soon be 47.
an associated press yahoo poll suggests
that mccain's advanced age is more of an
issue for voters than obama's relative
youth
and there were even many more questions
raised about president ronald reagan in
1984
let's go to the washington post shall we
they openly wondered if reagan had lost
his old fire
with age an article in the new york
times titled the age issue
claim that reagan's advisors knew that
he was struggling and quote
this is why they keep him out of press
conferences as much as possible
age may have been a factor in his
faltering performance
so one question what does the new york
times have to say about joe biden
being kept away from the press watch
this
and if i did this
mr president can you pass voting rights
with the senate full of the filibuster
in its current form do you think
i can talk to you about that mr
president mr president whatever happened
to your property
seven weeks ago that if democrats
flipped the senate the checks were going
out the door
come on peter thank you guys
mr president when will you unveil your
build that better plan
thank you thank you thank you and i'm
happy to take questions if that's you
i'm supposed to do nance whatever you
want me to do
so who made that decision to go to bars
and tone
well the new york times or washington
post or the ap
will they actually report on joe biden's
obvious struggles or
are these outlets just a propaganda wing
for the democratic party